president biden's massive infrastructure
law includes a landmark car safety
measure that was prompted by a six-year
cbs news investigation crash tests like
this one show the problem revealed by
our reporting a federal safety standard
dating back to 1967 leaves vehicle front
seats susceptible to collapse in rear
end crashes in response lawmakers passed
legislation aimed at addressing the
issue within two years chris vancleave
spoke with the colorado family that
spurred our reporting
16 sixteen-month-old taylor warner had
just started walking when a ride in the
family minivan turned deadly i've always
thought of trying to justify why did tay
die i don't want her to die in vain the
warners were rear-ended the force of the
crash caused her father andy's seat to
collapse backwards colliding with taylor
who was strapped in her car seat
sunday marked 11 years since that
accident her parents came to her grave
to reflect on how this year is finally
different
the newly signed infrastructure bill
mandates change inspired by the tragedy
that befell the warners and dozens of
other families identified by cbs news
when we spoke to you in 2015 we hadn't
really known where this was going to go
just thinking every day i'd get in the
car what if this happens again what if
we lose another child until this can
change
we found crash test after crash test
after crash test showing what can happen
when a seat collapses but every single
seat met or exceeded the
half-century-old federal strength
standard so does a banquet chair 200. in
the early 90s the national highway
traffic safety administration's own
researchers warned the agency about seat
back collapses citing examples of major
or fatal injuries and car makers have
long known it's an issue in a 1996
deposition a general motors engineer
said the cost to fix it was on the order
of a dollar or so per seat there are too
many lives of children that are being
needlessly lost crash investigator ken
sachalski has been trying to change the
standard since 1989 including on 60
minutes it's an inadequate standard it's
flawed as far as i'm concerned and again
in 2015 it's basically the same today as
it was then it's a worthless standard
three decades after you told nitza there
was a problem congress has passed
something that tells nitsa there's a
problem are you at least optimistic i am
optimistic i think it will get done in
response to our reporting massachusetts
senator ed markey introduced legislation
to fix the problem regulators now have
two years to draft a new strength
standard pending approval by the
secretary of transportation cbs and the
families put the spotlight
on this critical issue now it's time for
nitza to respond happy birthday as andy
and liz warner remember taylor 11 years
later they're now finding a moment of
peace amid their heartbreak you always
second guess yourself as being the
person that was in that seat knowing
that legislation is being passed helps
take some of that weight off my
shoulders we still miss her every day
but that we know that
her life meant something or we love her
and we're very proud of her and thank
her for what she's doing to help others
in the future
now nitza says safety is its top
priority and it will work to meet its
congressional mandates of course the
obvious question is where do you put
your children well safety experts
continue to tell us the back seat is the
safest place but to consider putting a
child behind the passenger seat if it's
empty or in the middle of the back seat
if both front seats are in use nate
it's a little tricky if you have a
family of four yeah no doubt about a
parent's worst nightmare these tragedies
that could be avoided they must prompt
change chris tremendous reporting i'm
sorry to interject i just have to say no
i get it and awareness you've got these
federal standards that are supposed to
protect people and they're not clearly
and now there's a two-year timetable to
address it what about all the people
driving around right now time is of the
essence yeah we can save children's
lives that's for sure chris thank you so
much